that's right that's it Eddie do you have
you done any movies yet no I hear you're
a magician a real talked about it bro
that's how I started in show biz you
crazy man terrified of any type of magic
you are sweating you did your research
that's how I started in show biz I was a
birthday party magician are you gonna
but you know I don't know do you like
birds
[Music]
not really
huh Mike tricks require like a little
setup so like I could leave the room and
then come back and do a cool trick but
you know right yeah oh you could leave
and come back and do it right they
require a little setup like had I known
you were gonna ask me I would have [ __ ]
in my pockets to do but like you know so
it's not [ __ ] no of course it's not real
magic is all [ __ ] because and that's
why I then when I was 15 was looked in
the mirror was like am I gonna be a
[ __ ] magician no I'm gonna so then I
switched it so you you thought that this
could be oh yes oh yes for sure
actually that's cool it's a real career
babe this bottle cap right here you know
like if I took it right here but yeah
and I say well what about these this one
because one time Oh
one time I do like a photo I drew a
picture and he ripped it up and then
like and then it was like in my pocket
or something oh yeah we're at the Magic
Castle how does that have you been there
will not take me because he's afraid of
it afraid I ain't in fact because you
know magic you're now at notch below
they
no more dick flex no no no but like how
do they do that I don't know you can't
you can't reveal yeah he knows this
[ __ ] guy no I really don't know he
knows the trade you know my member of
Magic Castle no but I like going there
but I you know I stopped I was learning
it up until I was like 15 and then I was
like I'm not gonna be a [ __ ] magician
so then I stopped so and what drew you
to it my grandpa did magic tricks at the
Thanksgiving dinner table and I got
interested I you know wanted to learn
about it and then in Chicago there's
magic shops and my dad to sign me up for
magic lessons and drove me into there
and how old were you then when you did
probably 13 12 13 oh that's amazing and
then I saw my first second City show
when I was like like 14 and I was like
oh this is what I want to do that's what
you really wanted to do because then I
looked on the wall at Second City and
there's all my heroes Bill Murray John
Belushi and I was like oh this is what
yeah yeah and now you are now here you
are in Hollywood and the hariom and
Bobby Lee is saying the second bedroom
[Music]